first thing you need to know about NATO
membership is all NATO countries it has
to be unanimous all NATO countries have
to approve an application for membership
and so after Russia invaded Ukraine a
couple of years ago what we saw was
Finland and Sweden saying enough with
the neutrality they wanted to be part of
the world's strongest military Alliance
NATO when they applied for membership
Finland was quickly approved Canada was
one of the first in fact to approve
finland's membership Canada was also one
of the first countries in the world to
approve Sweden's membership but not
everyone in NATO was on board with
Sweden necessarily in fact Hungary and
turkey for a long time were blocking
Sweden's membership last week Hungary
decided it would remove that block so
Hungary was on board and then late
Monday evening and some last minute
negotiations just before this Summit got
started turkey came on board president
erdogan and turkey said it was okay for
Sweden to join turkey had objected to
Sweden's membership for a couple of
reasons one turkey believes that what it
what turkey calls a Kurdish Terror
groups operate in Sweden took it in like
that and also Sweden has had some
islamophobic events over the last uh
last year or so and turkey which is a
Muslim country didn't think that the
Swedish government did enough to prevent
or combat these islamophobic events in
any event turkey has come to terms with
the idea of Swedish membership and now
look for Sweden to become the 32nd
member of the NATO alliance now who will
be the 33rd well I'll tell you what
Ukraine wants to be the 33rd member of
NATO and Ukraine has asked and pleaded
for a native to approve its membership
but NATO is a bit divided on Ukraine's
membership at this point and that's
because of the NATO treaty treaty
Article 5 says it you attack one NATO
member you attack them all so if Ukraine
became a member and that Russia
continued to attack Ukraine the NATO
treaty would compel all NATO members
really to get perhaps directly involved
in the war against Russia and some NATO
members don't believe that would be the
right thing to do at this time Ukraine
is here at this Summit Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski will be
talking to leaders including prime
minister Justin Trudeau about this idea
of membership and what you're going to
see here is NATO leaders again including
Canada if it's not going to be full
membership what else can NATO do to be
closer to Ukraine there's going to be
the first meeting of What's called the
NATO Ukraine commission again that's a
symbol of NATO and Ukraine coming
together but NATO leaders will also be
talking about perhaps some sort of
security guarantees and again more how
more Munitions more material can be
provided to Ukraine so Ukraine wants to
be the 33rd member of NATO it may not
happen at this summer but that doesn't
mean that this Summit is going to spend
a lot of time talking about the war in
Ukraine and what it can do to support
the ukrainians David Aiken Global News
Vilnius Lithuania